so then um
the next place we're going to do a
second last one
is what happens if i'm going to go back
to all of my original colors maybe you
want to do the same so get your repeats
out of the way
and put back
all of the colors there we go
now what if i want to arrange
rather than out of the n objects all of
them what if i only want to arrange some
of them and this is what i reserved k
for okay so the way i'm going to phrase
this question is
how many ways are there to arrange
k objects
from n choices
so i've got my
10 this number as my overarching theme
that's the number of things i can choose
from and then i only want k of them
right so let's go with say
this original 10
let's pick three of them okay let's just
make it nice and simple
so
in the first spot
i should say how many spots are there
well if i'm just picking three instead
of a row of ten i'm going to have
three boxes right one two three okay and
um draw the boxes draw them it might
take you long right and then you can
actually put this is part of your
argument even if your box looks like a
trapezium like mine
in the first spot in the first spot how
many choices do i have i still have ten
right just like here i still have ten so
then i pick one
and then i say okay i've got the next
spot to do so how many choices are there
now there's nine
and then there's eight
okay
so you can see what's missing here is
it's got the 10 factorial but there's
what's missing off the end
yeah it's like the 10 factorial with the
seven factorial chopped off okay in fact
i like just for myself when i'm
explaining this to other
i kind of like to say hey there's
actually bits missing here right there's
kind of like a factorial that's not
there right um
and so on okay
so in order to get rid of this right
this is 10 factorial and i've got to
divide through by this so that it
doesn't appear in the whole 10 factorial
term right so if i've got n choices i
start oops what column start with the n
factorial which in our case is 10
and i divide through by 7 factorial now
where does 7 factor in how does that
number emerge out of this
yeah so it's the 10 take away the three
that you've already got and that leaves
over however many okay so i'm going to
write n factorial on n minus k
factorial okay which in our case over
here that was ten factorial on seven
factorial
which is really
ten factorial on and take away three
factorial that's where the numbers come
from okay
all right now
i was so close
this leads us to our last and most
important and kind of most interesting
result which is to say this guy over
here which um as we know is given
special notation what do we call this
now this guy is super familiar right
super super familiar think back to the
start of this term i think back to like
the beginning of last year that is
almost exactly the same as
nc well in this case k right which of
course is there's no coincidence that
you use such similar notation um what is
m c k or ncr or whatever right um if i
just go with the case what's the
difference between this and that
yeah that's right so so all of these
pieces are still there it still has an n
factorial it still has an n minus k
factorial but in addition to those
it's got this guy hanging on okay so
there's lots of ways to get to this
result but i want to get to like what
does this mean in the context of all of
this i'm going to use these three pieces
i'm going to use all of them so think
carefully about what these mean
and i'm going to use them to generate
this result okay so you've got them
there on your paper i need this space
unfortunately so i'm going to
i can leave
okay so i'm going to leave his dot point
hanging for a moment and we'll come back
to him
let's start from this because it was the
closest to what will get us to here okay
let's think about our um
we said we were going to pick out oh
that green is really similar to the
other black there we go let's say we've
got that
okay so this is one of our arrangements
right this is one of our arrangements
now
in our case here like the actual numbers
i've got what would this be and the
answer is
this actual
the numbers of this
for our example would be 10 factorial on
3 factorial 7 factorial yeah you got you
can see these guys always add to n yeah
so when i look at this
the three factorial which is extra bit
that's come in
how is that related to this idea here
and keep in mind it's on the denominator
right now the idea is that you've got
three
the three it corresponds to these guys
that i've just chosen right now three
factorial is how many ways i have to
arrange these guys right so like for
example this one
and then this one and then this one and
there's six that i could do right in
fact
there you go okay i'm happy with that
all right
so here are six
arrangements our three factorial
arrangements of these guys okay now hold
on a second have a look um here we go
this is what i'm thinking about so i've
got my 10 factorial tell me why i
divided by 7 factorial tell me why go
back it's on the board why did i divide
by 7 factorial
because i didn't count those ones i've
only got three spots right so it's like
hey there are seven spots that actually
aren't in this situation so i divided by
seven factorial because i'm not even
arranging them okay that's good
and a three factorial
that doesn't come from like oh i've got
a different number of spots it comes
from the fact that hey there are three
factorial ways to arrange these
but if i'm not arranging them with
respect to like what makes these
different
answers
order makes them different right they're
all the same colors but i've put them in
different orders okay if i say well if
these are all the same
right and just say look just arrange
them just put them in a heap okay i
don't care about which one is first and
which one is second and which one is
third then all of these guys
if i if i should put them in a pile
they're all the same
they're all the same so i have over
counted if i don't care about their
order does that make sense so just like
here right um no sorry this one here
when we're looking at identical elements
right it's kind of treating these as
identical you can rearrange them and
still get the same pile
okay so here's our last thing
how many ways
now i can't see a range anymore i can't
say a range because i'm just putting
them in a pile right and it's like look
that pile and that pile and that pile
all identical okay so rather than using
the word arrange um i was avoiding the
word before because no one says
um i can say either i've got two choices
i can say
choose right because a choice like one
two three i'm still choosing the same
three no matter which way i turn them
around no matter which one of these i
have i've still chosen the same three
right so i'm going to say how many ways
to choose
and underneath there underneath there i
want to put the same
kind of idea but different word you can
also say how many ways i did to combine
these three right because if i were to
say okay here you go and whatever order
i don't matter it doesn't matter i've
combined the same three so they're
really amount to the same thing
so how many ways are there to choose and
it's it's the same thing here right it's
still k objects three
from the n choices the ten right so how
many ways are there to choose k objects
and you may like to because we've used
the word choose already you might like
to say m options right that's the way i
have it in my head anyway
okay
so the way i get to this is just like
when i started with um 10 factorial and
then i said whoops i over counted okay
i'm going to start with
mpk because that's how many ways there
are to get these guys right so that's
just thinking about the three spots so
that's
okay
but then i'm going to say hey this guy
has been overcounted quite a lot by a
factor of
k factorial right look three factorial
in this case or 4 factorial if i added
another one on ok
so npk on k factorial that of course is
n factorial on n minus k factorial big
set of brackets
all divided by k factorial you can see
this guy's going to
sneak onto that denominator and that's
in c
k
right